-Hello! Hello!
Thank you and be quiet!
Now, listen up, 'cause
I'm only gonna yell this once!
Was tonight the landslide
we dreamed of? No.
Was it the small victory
we expected? Also no.
I'd like to congratulate
my opponent
and America's favorite
tickle monster, Joe Biden.
I'm sure he is handling his
victory with humility and grace.
-Slap your ass and call
my lawyer. We did it!
Hey, man, no one thought I'd be
standing here on Super Thursday
in the great state of
what do ya call it.
No one!
But check your
record player, Jack,
'cause Uncle Joey made it!
-Look, was I hoping
to celebrate tonight? Sure.
I was ready to get lit!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was ready to get slizzered!
I was ready to get Tik Tok'd
and do a "leep-urd."
But instead,
Joe had a big night in the South
which luckily
has not gone to his head.
-Yee-hoo!
I got Texas! I got Alabama!
I got the whole dang
Old Town Road!
In fact, I was there
when they wrote the damn song!
-I won California.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I won Vermont.
Well, I better have won Vermont.
Last time I checked,
the state flag was
me, Ben, and Jerry hotboxing
in a North Face tent.
Come on, people!
-Now I want to introduce you
to some folks.
This is my sister Valerie.
-Sir, I'm a security guard.
-Oh. And this is my wife, Jill.
-No, I'm --
I'm the same security guard.
-Dagnabbit! They switched on me!
They s-- They switched on me.
-Now -- Now let me be clear.
It's still a tight race
between me and Joe,
so all I'll say is,
may the best man live.
-Uh, don't you mean
"may the best man win"?
-No, I do not. I do not.
-And l-let me tell you
something about Bernie.
You know who's fired up
for Bernie? Russia!
They want him to win.
You know who's fired up for me?
No one!
Hell, even I'm still on the
fence, and I am me, damn it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Listen to me. The coronavirus
has hit our shores.
We need a leader who knows
a thing or two
about a health crisis.
And look at me. Look at me.
I am a walking health crisis!
My Fitbit says, "Holy crap.
How is this guy still going?"
-And that's when I'll look
the coronavirus dead in the eye
and say,
"Back off, Buster Brown.
America's not open for business.
Not today, not ever!"
That right, Jimbo?
-Sir, who do you think I am?
-Luckily, it's not all bad
'cause earlier today
Mike Bloomberg dropped his
solid-gold ass out of the race.
Go home, Mike!
No one wants your money!
-Listen here, Mike.
I want your money.
I want all of it.
You can donate to me at
JoeBiden@skip-a-dee-doo-dah.net.
Thank you and thank you to the
great city of whatchamacallit.
You've been confusing.
-Joe! Joe! Joe! Joe! Joe!
-Hey, they're saying your name.
Joe! Joe! Joe! Joe! Joe! Joe!
Joe! Joe! Joe! Joe!